recently the CEO of Patagonia got
widespread media attention for donating
his company to charity while Jeff Bezos
announced that he'll give away most of
his fortune close to 120 billion we have
this idea that rich people are wealth
creators you know because they invest
the money 60 of Americans poll think
billionaires like Elon Musk are good for
the economy but the economic data
reveals something very different these
people become a black hole for wealth
and they start to suck the wealth out of
the economy where is all this wealth
actually going wired spoke to a former
Trader and an economist from Princeton
to debunk the top myths about the ultra
rich I'm not a moralist here I'm an
economist you know my job is to look at
the economy we currently exist in a
situation where the super rich are
getting massively richer very very
quickly but didn't that massive wealth
often start off humbly didn't Microsoft
and Amazon start out in a garage aren't
billionaires self-made to become a
billionaire you need to make a million
dollars every single day for three years
there are some self-made billionaires
but if you look at the statistics
increasingly more and more of them
inherited their money that's certainly
the case for The Waltons the Mars and
the Trump dynasties in fact according to
Forbes most of the ultra Rich grew up in
wealthy families or in the upper middle
or middle class it is becoming more
important how wealthy your parents are
if you want to be successful and you're
seeing this all over the world because
you are competing with the very rich for
the ownership of assets and these guys
have a passive income of billions of
dollars every year how are you earning
fifty thousand dollars a year ever going
to compete with that the share of income
going to the top one percent of
households that share has almost doubled
since the early 80s but although the
world's richest are earning twice as
much money as before it doesn't mean
they're investing twice as much when you
go and look at the data real investment
has actually gone down since inequality
has started to rise up according to
research done by Professor Mian and his
colleagues real investment by the ultra
rich is down by two to three percent
over the past few decades so even though
billionaires have been earning a lot
more compared to everyone else they
haven't been reinvesting that cash in
fact the top one percent saves an
average of 50 cents for every dollar of
disposable income they receive and
that's not good for the economy so if an
important part of the economy is not
consuming that money is not going into
investment that will ultimately lead to
a shrinking or a smaller economy than
before when which people invest they
don't necessarily have to create new
resources they don't need to necessarily
just build new factories they can use
that money to buy the existing houses
they can use that money to drive you and
your government into debt and that
doesn't lead to investment what it does
lead to is the impoverishment of the
middle class but how can you say that
when high-profile billionaires are
behind some of the largest employers in
the country don't billionaires create
new jobs that is when they aren't laying
off workers like Amazon Twitter and
Facebook just did the billionaires they
own the corporations they own the land
so of course they get to control who
works or not the very rich they are
saving a lot those savings are not going
into new business creation that saving
is not creating new jobs there has been
this slowdown in business creation uh
slow down in sort of more competition in
the economy that slow down in
competition from smaller businesses
doesn't necessarily mean that larger
companies like Walmart or Amazon will
increase their workforces as they become
more dominant increasingly a big part of
the thing I own is technology and
increasingly because of automation they
don't even need that many workers they
don't need human workers because they're
replacing the with robots by some
estimates automation is on track to
eliminate close to 20 million jobs
worldwide in manufacturing by 2030 but
aren't billionaires like Jeff Bezos Bill
Gates George Soros and Michael Bloomberg
making up for it by giving away tons of
wealth through charity whatever they
give they report on their tax returns So
based on all of that data data we know
that even after they give for
philanthropy they are saving a lot more
they should obviously acknowledge anyone
who gives money for philanthropic
reasons but it's not large enough to
actually negate the negative effects of
extreme inequality I think it's also
worth looking seriously into actually
how they get to charity and I think in
many cases these guys give the Charities
which they own in the case of Patagonia
the three billion dollar company was
transferred to a specially designed
trust overseen by the chunard family
moves like this could be seen as a
tactic to perpetuate wealth and avoid
taxes often only a small percentage of
certain Charities operating budget is
actually given directly away
philanthropy charity is fantastic well
done if you do it it is not going to
prevent this economy from going up the
edge of the cliff the only thing that
can do that is serious Reformation of
the tax system but some billionaires
like Elon Musk famously complain that
the government already takes too much in
taxes it's actually not true that the
very rich pay on lot as a fraction of
their income in taxes it is remarkable
how flat a tax system the U.S has and so
by and large people are paying roughly
similar Sense on the dollar of income
whether you are in the middle class the
upper middle class or the billionaire we
have a Taxis now it's very very good at
taxing working people but rich people
because their income comes in a variety
of different ways capital gains
inheritance and those are forms of
income in which it is very easy to
legally avoid tax so although High
earners in the top income bracket May
pay up to 37 percent in taxes
billionaires like Warren Buffett whose
income is from the stock market use
loopholes to wind up paying very low tax
rates but at the moment for the very
riches it's effectively says zero
percent rate of tax I think Edo must pay
zero tax for a couple of years in a row
and he's the victims man the world very
very wealthy people like the Duke of
Westminster in my country they get
billions in income of their lifetime and
pay nothing so what's the solution to
widening income inequality a so-called
wealth tax wealth tax on very high
levels of wealth that would actually be
a good thing in this economy because
that will take away some of that excess
in savings and channel that back into
the economy through spending in the 50s
60s and 70s top rates of tax estate
taxes and income taxes were massively
higher and that was a period where the
economy was growing where ordinary
families could buy houses you know where
standard living was good for ordinary
people in fact during the post-world War
II era up until the 80s there was
actually a decline in income inequality
the gap between the Haves and have-nots
was narrower according to Professor Mian
total Factor productivity which measures
production output efficiency was higher
too the economy's growth was more
Equitable and more robust so we now live
in times where growth has been more
unequal the taxation has been less
Progressive and this fundamental measure
of growth which is total Factor
productivity has actually slowed down as
well if you put money in the hands of
Ordinary People ordinary families they
will spend it that will drive the
economy if you put all of the money in
the hands of they're very rich then
there will be no spending and they will
use that money to buy the rest of the
assets which will make the middle class
poorer still so given that data why does
the misperception that tackling income
inequality will damage economic growth
persist you need to understand that
these people they have political
influence you know and in many cases
they own you know they own newspapers
and they own their own news channels so
they're going to try to convince you
that it is good there's an unbelievable
power imbalance and they are using that
power to get more of the existing
resources and more of the existing power
so if we don't take action that pattern
balance is only going to get worse over
time
foreign